I wanted to start by asking you a little
bit about the fact you know you've
talked a lot about being influenced by
70s movies like Serpico and once loved
the Cuckoo's Nest and taxi driver and
I'm curious if the starting point for
this was you wanted to make a movie in
that tradition and then tried to figure
out a way to kind of smuggle it into the
system or was it started with the
character Joker and won and you just
figured out that was the right language
for it what were this was the starting
point I have made a lot of movies about
multiple characters and I really wanted
to do a deep dive sort of character
study into one person and those are
tougher to get made they're not not made
I mean social network is sort of a
character study there will be blood is
maybe the best one in the last 20 years
but they don't get made a lot in the
studio system and it's tough to get
people to show up to them and and so
then I sort of had this little bit
twisted idea of well maybe you can get
it made if you made it about one of
those guys meaning you know so it was a
little bit what you said smuggling it
through but I'd always been I'm not a
huge comic book movie person I see the
movies and I appreciate them for for
what they are and Chris Nolan's movies
are incredible
but uh so I thought oh I've always liked
the Joker of that whole thing and so it
kind of was a little bit of both in a
way but but but some you know with all
due honesty and in all honesty it was a
little bit of kind of pushing a movie
like that through through the system and
so someone what was the writing process
like with Scott silver how long did it
take you guys to hash out this script
and you start do you start out knowing
what the basic story is gonna be do you
just start with the character what's the
evolution of the screenplay so I thought
of that idea and I called up Scott
we had never written together but I've
known him for years and we've always
talked about working together and I said
I have this crazy idea and I told him
what it was which is 10% of what this is
as any writing is and we just started
meeting and fleshing it out and it was a
really a series of backwards engineering
and thinking okay what do we know about
Joker well he has a laugh well he has
white face painted and green hair and
all these sort of things that we've come
to know about Joker and then running
them through as realistic a lens as
possible well why does he have a white
face it well in the comics he fell into
a vat of acid I don't believe that if
you fall into a vat of acid you're gonna
have a white face and green hair so it
was about running everything through a
very you know giving him an affliction
for his laughs and and really what I
would to go back to your first question
the exciting thing about doing a
character study for me was how all the
other things in the movie become
characters whether it's the
cinematography or the music which i
think is a huge character in this film
the production design these all become
kind of front and center in a different
way and it was it was really exciting
what kinds of conversations did you have
with Todd initially about what the
influences and references were gonna be
light and and what did you take from
those 70s movies what did you recognize
in their cinematography that you thought
was applicable here yeah I think that
puts it pretty squarely on the head
which is it was less about referencing
them very specifically and more about
our memory of what those movies were and
their influences on us as filmmakers is
just an audience member and what our
memory of that time in space was
certainly it's like we guard making a
movie that's a period piece of a city
that is similar in in essence to New
York Todd grew up in New Yorker group
across the bridge in New Jersey so we I
had familiar memories and I think that
was in large part what influenced the
look and feel the specific references to
those movies were less oh and even if we
did reference them because we thought oh
network would be great let's look at the
talk show or whatever it is on some
specific thing even king of comedy which
people think like the movie is like oh
you know reference like they they're
like Louie what's going look at that
shot and I'm going we never even watched
King of Comedy so but in our lives a
million yeah yeah but meaning go shot
that's exactly right yeah yeah and even
taxi driver I hadn't seen in 10 years
but but I also but I did look at it a
little bit specifically to replicate we
talked a little bit about like as if it
felt like it could have been made in
that time that was like the main
influence of those
those movies of that era was like yeah I
mean it's funny when we would talk about
these things and having it look like
that any time we set up a shot to
actually look like that it didn't feel
like this film so in a weird way it was
just in the DNA of the movie I kind of
say it is like I just wanted to feel
like it could have come out in the
summer of 1979 but it's not necessarily
while Scott and I for sure referenced
all those movies when we were writing it
and we watched all those movies just as
far as pace and tone when we got down to
shooting it it's not like you go oh
that's the shot from so-and-so and
that's the thing it was just more in its
blood so to speak
Jeff something that is really
interesting about your editing in this
movie is you're dealing with a very
unreliable narrator and I think watching
it again tonight and this was my second
viewing and I really appreciated the way
you kind of calibrated how much we know
you know what's what's real what's clear
what's ambiguous how difficult was that
you know Mountain sort of modulating
that throughout the editing process I
think the most difficult thing really
was modulating that it's we you know if
each individual scene was was always
kind of working by actually putting them
in the right order and saying okay how
do we how do we tighten the screws on
Arthur and at the same time like loosen
the leash on Joker over the course of
the movie was was I guess the biggest
challenge and something that we were I
think from day one through even during
production we were looking at yeah well
the whole evolution of him
you know from Arthur to Joker is really
nice sort of steady and and sort of
creeps up on you and Larry what were you
thinking photographically in terms of
you know conveying that to the audience
that change I mean I had some a lot of
it was compositional things in terms of
just giving him a different kind of
weight and perspective as he became
Joker a little bit more power some of
that was compositional stuff some was
lighting keeping him like taught it
early on in the process I'd mentioned
this thing about the shadow of a man or
you know and that it what if you were
actually your shadow instead of your
sort of lit self and you were the
darkest part of yourself and I kind of
held on to that and then would write
things in the margins of scenes to sort
of subtly show that photographically
through lighting in terms of not just
the physical darkness but how he sat
against his landscape where there was
more silhouetted shadows in the frame
those kind of things I mean there's
never a shot in the movie that's at eye
level and that was intentional from the
beginning that even when he's Arthur
there's always just slightly odd framing
and and we tried to do that throughout
the movie to just set him either small
in frames to show his insignificance in
a larger world
or when we were very close with him to
just be at an angle that was not
traditional and tried to do that
throughout the movie and on a technical
level I'm curious how you arrived at the
idea of shooting it with large format
digital I mean did you guys ever talk
about doing it on film since it was a
period piece I'm laughing because
there's all we talked about and we did
so many tests and so many things I'll
let you finish yeah I mean literally it
was like the first thing we said when he
handed me the script was it was like
we're shooting on film we're not doing
this digital [ __ ] and I'm like you
got it boss and we shot area 65 digital
because yeah exactly right so we got
there a little bit for various reasons
first of all we would we actually wanted
to shoot large format film and even with
a movie of this budget it was still not
really feasible you know the cameras
weren't available it was too much money
there are you know things like that was
the original thing was to shoot large
format film and then Warner Brothers
kind of shut us down on that quite
frankly and then I was like alright well
they're not even said to you we got to
shoot 16 millimeter film it won't ya
know even further the other direct right
I just wanted to I thought like you were
initial instinct well we're setting it
then we're saying came out in the summer
of 79 we should shoot it on film but
then when we started running tests and
we really wanted so much of all this
stuff was about Joaquin and because it
just remind me when you were talking to
Jeff about you know the balance of
certain things and it was all to honor
his performance and the more I got to
know Joaquin the more I realized we want
to be able to be on our feet move rather
quickly
like the
so what keen isn't the kind of actor
where you go are you gonna walk in the
store you're gonna sit here you pick up
this water and then on that line you get
up and walk over there it's just not
that guy which is a myth which is what
makes him amazing
so Larry had the light rooms so we could
shoot in any direction at any time and
do anything and I think we realized
after getting because I was spending
months with Joaquin talking about the
script and Larry spending a couple
months as we're doing camera tests
telling me why digital for this would be
better and I'm going you know what
knowing what I'm dealing with with
Joaquin in a great way the freedom and
the flexibility that he would want it
just made sense that's right and and and
frankly and I am a fan as a
cinematographer I actually recognize the
attributes that digital has and the
photography elements and the precision
and all these things but I also
recognized this intrinsic thing in this
aspect of the magic is gone with with
digital and and I really respected that
with Todd cuz it's a distraction like to
see exactly what you're gonna do instead
of seeing some crappy monitor and then
the next day it's magical when you get
it back from the lab I respect that even
more now having shot digital and so my
promise is Todd was like if we do it
this way I promise we will try to stay
as true to a chemical look as we
possibly can and so I worked really hard
to give it a look that my only goal
frankly was that at some point in the
process Todd wasn't gonna turn to me and
go oh we should a shot film it still
might happen by the way like it's like
we the weekends still young but like but
but nonetheless he hasn't and I'm really
happy with the way the movie looks and
we've tricked a lot of people into
thinking it was shot on film and in
large part that was a thing about the
look was what are those qualities that
film has and how can you replicate that
but yeah it's funny because not to make
this a film digital thing but ultimately
the key to the movie was that it felt
handmade to me and intimate and that was
a thing I just didn't feel you'd feel
with digital but weirdly when we started
doing these tests and the way Larry
shoots and the way Larry lights it
actually felt more hand made to me the
way he was doing it so that was kind of
the ultimate decision yeah it'll
actually allowed us to do this and
Ava's a tional thing from a camera
standpoint with Joaquin in a way that
technically we weren't gonna have that
terrible phone call of like that whole
take is just out of focus enough that's
unusable and and that would have been
just tragedy because there were a lot of
times in which one take was all we were
gonna get of that thing walking is
beautiful in the way that he doesn't
really give you the same thing twice in
the best possible way which brings us
back to Jeff because that is really the
magic of and and really what Jeff and I
tried to do in the editing room was
honor that performance and and what you
just said that that that that uh
transformation from Arthur to Joker
does not happen with his entombed booth
and come out and he's Joker it happens
over two hours it's the slow burn so I
think Jeff's biggest job in the editing
room was honoring that performance and
keeping that really slow burn going with
at the same time with never having the
same thing done twice right well I want
to ask you about that Jeff I mean the
challenge of how many takes do you have
of any given scene of Joaquin and how if
they're all different how how are you
making those decisions throughout which
take to use I mean are some are they are
some clearly the best or is he giving
you four equally great versions that are
totally different and you have to choose
between them he was giving four equally
great versions I think the way that you
ultimately do it is you just start
building and you take what you what you
think is the best at the time and then
you build the context around it and then
as that context changes the best take
changes or it doesn't I mean sometimes
you get it right on the first try and
sometimes it's it's a different thing
but we did ultimately in wanting onto
that performance kind of go back through
and remove cuts from the movie just to
make sure that we weren't over
manipulating what he was doing I want to
thank you guys for coming and talking
about the movie with us